This is a really great question because
everyone wants to know how we might you
know improve regenerative outcomes and
human patience right and so one way that
you can really start to think about how
to do that is to ask the question what
are the genes that enable axolotls to
regenerate so well? and if you have the
whole genome then you can consider all
the genes because you know you have the
identity of all the genes and so what we
can do is we can say what are the genes
that help Axolotl's are necessary for Axolotl's to regenerate and then we can
compare those genes to the genes in the
human and we can say okay do humans have
these genes or do they not have these
genes and for ones the humans might not
have we can say what would happen if you
gave for instance a mammal that gene for
instance what would be the consequences
could you at some level improve
regeneration maybe even just a little
bit and then another thing you can do is
say okay what about for the genes that
both axolotl's and humans and mice all of
them have are they a hundred percent
identical you know do they make the
exact same protein or not and do all the
same cells make that kind of protein etc
so you can go in and actually compare
you know point by point to see exactly
how similar or different they are and
that will give you some clues about you
know where they might where they might
be different and if they're important
for regeneration you could say well
maybe the human one is perhaps broken in
this spot right so that would be really
important. It's also really important
experimentally for us to be able to
assign function to particular genes. The
gold standard in genetics is to remove
them so to delete the gene and then see
what the consequences on the thing
you're studying so in this case
regeneration and with the technologies
that we have now so for instance CRISPR
editing technologies you can do that if
you know what gene you're studying but
if you don't know what all the other
genes are that the axolotl has you might
secretly be mucking with one of the
other ones or many of the other ones and
so having the whole genome allows us to
much better predict what might be the
accidental you know what we call off
target genes that we might also be
hitting so that we can be much more
specific about saying okay we are
studying this one particular gene and
this is its function rather than not
knowing that we're really disrupting a
whole bunch of different ones at the
same time.